hi guys it's silver at again and today
we won't be doing any tasty time lapses
because I'm going to build a
rollercoaster a free fly rollercoaster
thingy that I've got over there alright
so this I think will be the basic path
of the lift Hill and then I'll have it
go around this mountain and add some
scenery to that later on then make it go
all the way over there I think make it
go around here and do some scenery
interaction there then make it go over
here and have either a tunnel or a
bridge over it
wait no and that's going to be hard
because you don't have to go back there
so I'll have to add a bridge or
something over here well I've no clue
how I'm going to do that but I'll
forgive you that somehow so um I think I
want to start up with an infinite
corkscrew and then see what else I can
come up with you know I think I might
have stumbled upon a jackpot right here
I was just experimenting with this did a
little thing here it's kind of cool when
it's pretty smooth then I'm going to try
to add a tunnel in here not sure if it's
going to work out because there's many
places where I'll get collisions like
over here for example because this needs
to be above the ground and this needs to
be a tunnel so that's going to be quite
hard
then another helix and another helix you
can't have you know felix's on these
things but the last part is going to be
a bit hard because I'm going to have to
figure out what to do with this little
thing in here and of course I'm going to
expand on this this won't be the only
Tower
I'll make this into a full-grown castle
I need to know the coasts of the layout
before I do that so that's why I'm going
to mess with right now and this is going
to be the hardest part I think so yeah
you know I guess I might do something
like this I've never seen this before on
a free fly coaster but might work out
now the zero-g roll seems to be very
smooth and it's not too fast
and when I've I want the ending to be
faster than the rest of the ride like
the entire right it seems to accelerate
first part it's a bit slow then it goes
a little bit faster you've got you've
got that little sono over there maybe
I'll make this into a tunnel as well not
sure about that
then little fast bite over here super
far zero zero and then
Sonic's the names
it's my game but except this this my
it's not going to be called Sonic
despite the color scheme for now I'm not
sure about this blue collar either
because you know everything is different
colors but I won't have some contrast
and though so this is the layout then
and so I think I can do something with
this it looks pretty cool from aerial
view and this part looked really cool
from right here although I'm not too
happy about this area here it's a bit
rough but you know I guess I have to do
with that because it was I've tried
multiple things and nothing really works
out over there because it's it's not a
lot of space and I wanted to have a
castle there and I wanted the coast it's
go around that's so I have to do that I
have to put up with this then but right
now I still have some time left to do
the station so I might as well do that
I've had
she's mine
nice
made me feel
Oh
and I'm still
is a
try
my
I
always been
I must be out of my
so ah that's that's about it for today
I guess stations looking meh especially
this roof of course I'm going to add
windows and other stuff to that and
probably a different shape roof over
here somewhere in the middle just for
some variety but for now I don't want to
do this anymore
that sounds okay look I need to start
all over
I'm Way too depressed right so um yeah
now beautiful so amazing I love life and
yeah whoa very impressive and yeah I'm
going to make cool things look at that
station whoa whoa
great whoa and basically next up next
episode I am going to finish that
station because obviously it's not
finished right now and I'm going to
start doing the rock work and supports
over here especially the rock work
that's going to be kind of a pain in the
ass I guess but I guess the final result
will be awesome because I always love
terrain hugging coasters with tunnels
and I've never done a free fly coast
before and they're really awesome so
yeah really love it really love attack
on Titan by the way can't stress done
you know right there
but till next episode